we're about to hear from a woman who
played a key role in Harvey Weinstein's
sex crimes trial in California a jury in
Los Angeles as you've heard this morning
convicted the disgrace movie producer on
three counts yesterday including rape
and sexual assault ambra badalana
Gutierrez provided vital testimony about
his previous misconduct she caught
Harvey Weinstein on tape appearing to
admit to groping her back in 2015.
prosecutors never charged him in that
case but her accusation encouraged other
women to come forward ambro badalana
Gutierrez joins us now at the table good
morning we're glad you're here good
morning I know that this has been very
tough this has been a great a huge
ordeal for you and I'm wondering your
thoughts after you heard the verdict
yesterday
uh it's a feeling of relief like
I just am happy that people believe me
right now people believe me and other
victims this wasn't easy back in 2015 I
was 22 years old I'm Italian so English
wasn't my first language but I knew that
what I was doing was right but back in
2015 you were a lone voice you know
there was nobody who was saying what you
were saying yeah and your encountered
with Harvey Weinstein started because
you had gone to a casting audition right
yes and what happened I am a model still
now and as every day I go to castings I
wouldn't ever expect that walking to
that office during daytime with people
working outside the office it would have
happened that he assaulted me and and
after basically I left I went right away
to the police I reported it they did not
believe you
let's say the police tried to help me
they tried to do as much the the cold
but he was so powerful he was able to
just make me
non-believable and destroyed me
basically in any way he could if I had
to leave New York I had to go live
somewhere else it was just like living
all my dreams here and it wasn't easy
but your testimony number helped other
women have the courage to come forward
and you ultimately ended up testifying
against him in court what was that like
for you to face him in the courtroom
for me it was um a filling of of being
powerful again
in 2015 when I worked with the police
they were able to to put it on a tape
and and they had basically him saying
what he did to me and it was recorded it
was also video footage on the security
cameras so confronting him for me was
like
you know finishing that story to a good
ending to to give the example that
whatever I had done was was the right
way even if it was so hard that was to
be done to Believe In Justice do you
believe that we are in a better place as
a society
I feel that now there is more of a feel
of security of a feeling of safety on in
in the justice system
um where
um like situation of uh especially
sexual assault or or even sexual abuse
can be more listened and it can be like
persecuted
that before probably there wasn't that
much of that belief so yeah what do you
hope happens to Harvey Weinstein in
terms of sentencing out in LA
well more than anything more than the
sentence in La uh I'm just more like
um relaxed about what's going to happen
in New York because you try to appeal so
that was making me very very
upset and worried already could walk
free exactly but what do you think Amber
as we sit here today his lawyers are
saying he still denies all of these
allegations when you hear that what do
you think
I can't believe that someone that faced
so many of the victims face to face in
in this trials
cannot understand that he did something
wrong like
I
I was born and raised Catholic Christian
and you know the basis is like trying to
forgive people have you forgiven him and
that's what I was trying to say like I I
just cannot I don't see any type of
regret in in his eyes like it just felt
so
unbelievable when I was there on the
stand looking at him looking at the
footage and the audio of him admitting
what he did yeah so interesting to hear
you talk about the eyes because there's
the legal strategy whatever your lawyers
are recommending he doesn't want to
admit this or that but then there's the
eyes yeah for you to bring that up I
think it's so honest and revealing I
know the healing process takes time but
where are you right now and what advice
would you give to anyone that has been
through I
I'm feeling at a point where I know that
my story is relevant it's going to help
other people and that's why I'm trying
to push for laws to try and help victims
that didn't have possibilities before to
get justice so now it's past the adult
survivors act and is this law in New
York state that can open a one-year look
back window for victims of sexual
assault adult victims and they can try
to civilizue against their abusers in a
safety place that now we are in wherever
too it's here and people are listening
and it must give you some validation and
comfort and encouragement to know people
believe you as we sit here in 2022
compared to where we were in 2015 yes
true yes a lot of work but I got to this
point yeah
Gutierrez thank you so much for joining
us I appreciate your sharing